foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm Dave
Ramsey your host you jump in Chris Chris
what's your name George Campbell Ramsay
personality is my co-host we don't even
have a Chris that is a Ramsay
personality so uh but stupid yeah I'm
not going to call you stupid you're not
you're not on that list open phones
today as we talk about your life and
your money triple eight eight two five
five two two five huge day here at
Ramsey you know something's different if
I'm wearing a hoodie and I'm matching
and you're we have matching hoodies
we're a boy band oh God help us oh
that's awful well the reason we're
wearing hoodies is we are celebrating
the launch today of the Ramsey gazelle
debit card we have been working on this
literally for two years and millions of
dollars has gone into it so far and
today is the official public launch we
are very very excited about this it is
something we have dreamed about and
thought about for a very long time why
do we have a gazelle debit card well
from the day that debit cards came out I
told you to get one I have not carried a
credit card in three decades I carry two
debit cards you've heard the story I
have four pieces of plastic in my pocket
my debit card on my business my debit
card on my personal account my driver's
license and my handgun carry permit
that's the entire thing in my wallet
except green prices except green faces
of Dead Presidents and uh they're in
there too but we carry debit cards here
we use debit cards we do not use credit
cards at Ramsey we teach people to not
use credit cards to have plastic surgery
and Shop up your credit cards and we
teach you that the debit card has the
same fraud protections as a credit card
and we teach you you will not overspend
when you're using a debit card because
if you don't have money in your account
you will bounce freaking checks so you
use a debit card because you're a
responsible human being we teach you all
of these things we have carried I have
carried a debit card since the day they
came out I've always had a Visa debit
card or a MasterCard debit card the
particular Bank we deal with now is a
MasterCard company so my personal
accounts are with our my personal banker
our MasterCards and the gazelle card the
bank that we're running it through is a
MasterCard debit card and it's a world
debit card it is an absolutely fabulous
graphic it looks amazing I mean it's
amazing I've never seen it actually like
a cool looking debit card really I mean
to accomplish that or credit card it was
a low bar yeah it was fairly easy to
beat the competition on that so but this
one no fees no fees no gotchas we're not
going to run commercials of pretty
people like freaking Sofi and try to
make you think we love you and then
screw you which is what they do we love
you and then we don't screw you go
figure we don't take advantage of you
we're not going to send you a bunch of
ads for a bunch of home equity loans
we're not going to sell your name to
other people and go oh you can sell
these people debt you can sell these
people dead see that's what debit cards
are for most banks they're lost leaders
that they use to get people on the hook
it's the gateway drug Dave it's the
Gateway it's how they get you in it's
the opener well this isn't a gateway
drug it's the beginning and the end
right there it is a complete debit card
process fully online fully FDIC insured
fully fraud protected just like any good
MasterCard debit card is and it is a
gazelle card but the best part about it
of all is when you use it people are
going to go wow what is that what are
you doing and you go man I'm gazelle
intense I'm getting out of debt I'm I'm
wise with my money I'm not spending like
I'm in Congress you are signaling other
people that you are Financial freaking
adult and an unintentional effect is
that when you go to swipe you kind of
think you see the gazelle on there and
it reminds you of hey I want to do this
the Ramsey he's not a little wimpy
because I mean he's got his intense
attitude I mean he's got to look at him
he's got it right there I'm not messing
with him he's uh he's a dude man I mean
he's got style we talked about putting a
little red eye in there so he looked
like a devil but he looked like a devil
Beast yeah
but uh man this guy's he's not this is
not a gazelle that's scared no this is
gazelle that's getting her done it's
intense you know and so good stuff good
stuff so the gazelle debit card is out
there there are already thousands of
people using it because we run it
through beta tests and everything else
and to make sure everything's working
before we go public Today George and I
have done uh what 10 interviews this
morning on television stations around
the nation including Fox and Friends
this morning announcing this launch
we've been up since 4am doing this stuff
I need coffee but the uh man I'm telling
you this thing this is an incredible
product it makes a statement about who
you are we're not going to get you with
fees it's got all the same protections
um and you ought to try it out oh
absolutely and if you're in every dollar
user seamless integration with every
dollar because we own both experiences
there and so there's some really cool
features that the team is continuously
going to be working on to make this
better and better like it's really
really fast how fast your charge when
you you know you run the card how fast
it shows up in your every dollar app
really fast so one of the best features
we you know we're the people that like
you said we got both of these digital
things going on and we have digital
Geniuses in this building you and I are
not one of those we have some here and
we know that they do stuff we're not
sure what stuff they do but the stuff
they did allowed those two things to
talk every dollar and the gazelle card
and can you be clear Dave we are we are
not a bank we are not becoming a bank no
partnering with we're not going to get
you into that this this begins and ends
here it's a process for spending and
saving the Ramsay way and it and for you
stupid butt people on social media you
stupid butt trolls Dave Ramsey's in his
MasterCard Dave Ramsey's got a
MasterCard debit card in his pocket for
25 years so shut the flip up okay you
stupid butt people it's not inconsistent
I didn't sell out there's nothing
different here and I've always told you
use debit cards and a lot of debit cards
have cash back like at a not cash back
or you savings you can go in like if
you're using it uh this one is what
Starbucks is one of the ones or whoever
I don't even know it's a huge long list
of companies that when you use it there
you'll get a discount and that's through
our partner at NetSpend yeah and
NetSpend is the bank behind this the
banking process behind this and they
already had all that set up so you get
the savings on this stuff but we're not
trying to get you to spend money to save
on your stupid coffee that's not the
idea the whole idea is to do the all the
stuff we've been teaching you all along
we didn't change a thing we're just
giving you a better way to do it
so and if you don't like that troll your
butt off because you're an idiot okay
that just goes but there's that's what
trolls are they're idiots in general
anyway so just keep it up people just
keep it up yeah Master Card and I'm
gonna keep calling you idiots too I'm
beginning to think almost anybody on
social media is but I'm not ready to go
quite that far because I still check
Instagram well you're on there too Dave
so well I know they put me on there but
I'm not on there and I'm certainly let
me tell you how many times I have
commented negatively on someone on
social media other than Twitter on
someone else's thing other than on
Twitter now I've gone back at people on
Twitter I used to have these Twitter
fights in the old days that was a lot of
fun back when Twitter was cool Twitter's
completely devolved now it's it's
devolved into a sewage pit but uh the
number of times I've gone on someone
else's Instagram account and posted
negatively precisely zero means the
number of times I posted a negative book
review on anyone's book ever
precisely zero I've told people in
private don't read it it's trash but I'm
not gonna go out there I don't have time
to do that I have a thing called a life
we're launching products out here folks
that's it we're helping people with
stuff like the new gazelle debit card a
good reason to wear stylish hoodies cool
hoodies.com
[Music]
man not something I would have designed
but something I get to wear makes me
look 25 years younger this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we just returned from Dallas all the
Ramsey personalities and Pastor Craig
and Amy groschel were speaking all day
long at the Smart conference in Dallas I
think it was our best smart conference
ever George you did a great job on stage
oh thank you funny fun entertaining
informative and inspiring all the stuff
you needed to be well done I appreciate
that all the personalities had amazing
talks across so many areas I mean from
career to mental health relationships to
money I mean people left in tears they
were laughing they were crying and I
hope there's a lot of lives transformed
absolutely good stuff open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Betsy is with us in Asheville North
Carolina hi Betsy Welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey thanks so much for taking my call
and I'm absolutely going to get a
gazelle card well thank you
I love it how can we help today
um I you've changed my life um but I
think it might be too late for me and I
needed to kind of tell you that
um I I've been more fortunate than a lot
of people I've flown through many
thousands of dollars I've had big shots
of money from various things uh
inheritances whatever
um and basically I am 66 years old I
sold my business four years ago for two
hundred thousand dollars
and I sold a house I'm now renting very
cheaply and um
I have
about two hundred thousand dollars still
and I'm living on six to seven hundred
dollars a month because I've lived very
cheaply but I wanted to give you the
numbers and and have you laugh at me and
say no you're not going to make it
because my core values are freedom and
Independence
and it petrifies me to think
um that I won't have Financial you know
stability and I'm unable to work because
of a neurological
condition where it can't be upright
spherionophen
so should I just give you the numbers
yeah that's fine sure
okay I invested a hundred thousand
dollars a year ago in a local commercial
lender they do alternative lending to to
people that don't go through traditional
Banks and that's a that's a guaranteed
eight percent a year so that 100 000 has
turned into a hundred to eight thousand
I put forty five thousand dollars in the
Vanguard last year when I first found
you guys and it's down to thirty eight
thousand
um of course I'm not selling it but um
that hurts it's basically a wash on what
I made from the other investment
um I have my IRAs are about 17 000 and
my cash is about eight about nineteen
thousand so somewhere between I don't I
don't know the ad up of that but
I go through my expenses in my budget
every month and I say okay six hundred
dollars a month divided by or 100 let's
see eighteen thousand dollars divided by
600 a month oh good I can lift 24 more
months on that before I have to tapped
into my investments
but am I am I just um living a pipe
dream am I going to be if I can really
stick to a budget
uh you're not collecting Social Security
oh that I don't even include that
because that actually pays my rent
it's a wash I get a thousand dollars I
pay a thousand dollars so basically I
spend 600 out of my savings about six or
seven hours savings
I see okay and my Social Security will
be going up of course but um
you know and you're making 8 000 on one
investment and the other investment
because the Market's down is down right
now
okay and tell me again what you put in
Vanguard again
I put 45 000 in I put 15 000 in the uh
what's the one that you have a minimum
of fifteen thousand like the silver or
the yeah I've got some word for it is in
that and thirty thousand so you only
have a hundred and fifty thousand
no I have almost 200 I have 108 plus the
original 45 right let's just call it
that yeah and then in my in my savings
I've got 19. oh actually yeah for your
emergency phone yeah and my IRAs I've
got 1700 okay I mean 17 000. and I'm
trying to see if I can live on
six to seven hundred dollars a month and
stretch it out until I'm like I'm 66 so
I mean if I don't want to get married
five six or six six
yeah I'll be 67 next month okay all
right well I uh
yes you're gonna make it and no it's not
a pipe dream and no it's not all come to
an end
um it's the worst possible year to have
this conversation with Vanguard going
the wrong direction which is an unusual
thing uh I don't know exactly what you
put that in but if you're just in a good
growth stock mutual fund it would be
down this year the Market's down yeah
and uh most years is up it's an unusual
little bad economy that we're in and
um a lot of reasons for that but that's
not the purpose of this call so um right
and I'm hoping by next year we see a
turnaround yeah because I'm going to go
early vote this afternoon just to make
sure we do but um
but anyway the uh uh
well I'm
can I just insert one more thing sure I
come from a family of such Spenders that
it is
it's really hit me this month that I've
still been spending too much and so now
I'm I'm 100 a month is too much
no I spent 2000 in September oh so
you're not sticking to your budget
I am now okay but no okay I mean
whatever budget you set you have to put
that into your projections and then if
you don't stick to it you screw up your
projections
right so that that's that's that's the
third variable that you've added now and
yeah I will say you got to do that or
you whatever I mean because I don't care
if you make 50 000 a month and you spend
sixty thousand you still got a pipe
dream right definitely so um that's the
thing so I I would tell you this I want
you to sit down with a smartvester pro
and uh stir this portfolio a little and
see if we can't make it do a little
better over the Long Haul okay I don't
know what that it would do better on the
short haul if you had done what I told
you to do like with the money if you've
done that two years ago you might be
worse off right now than you are right
now because the Market's down and I I'm
62 and
um I'm 100 I don't I'm 100 invested in
the market
I mean and pulled anything out but uh
but but in a little different situation
so yeah I think sitting down with Smart
Vista Pro sticking to your budget you
got you know then lay your projections
out but I think overall you probably can
do better than either one of these
Investments but not a ton
uh and then the third thing I would tell
you is this
had a perfectly normal conversation here
with you for three or four minutes five
minutes
so there is some things you can do even
if it's just a few hours a day or a week
even if it's just uh finding something
online that you you know you sell stuff
on eBay whatever it is you're able to do
with the limitations that you have with
the the medical process you're facing
I'm still gonna find something I can do
to because here's the thing if you add a
thousand dollars a month to this
by working uh five hours a week doing
something online you know or or on the
phone or something uh you change this
num you change the situation
dramatically a thousand dollars a month
changes your whole math picture with the
numbers you're giving me because they're
so small
and so I'm gonna think about what you
can do within the limitations I'm not
trying to say you you've been lazy or
something you're certainly not that but
you're very articulate very quick very
uh intelligent on the phone so that
means there's things you can do yeah and
if this year you were able to live off 8
000 you know maybe with compound
interest next year we shoot for nine
thousand and then ten thousand over the
next 10 years as the money continues to
grow and you continue to live on a
budget we can make this work but right
now it might be tight for this year yeah
yeah but overall is is there hope
there's hope because you're breathing
and there's hope because you're paying
attention it's not too late and if you
pay attention and you keep breathing
then you're there so I met this lady the
other day that's 100 years old
100 years old sitting in a rocking chair
on her porch she's a neighbor to a farm
I own and I said so what's your secret
how do you live to be a hundred
she granted she said don't stop
breathing
that is 100 year old lady humor right
there oh
two-year-old I cracked up man I laughed
all the way home this is the red Ramsey
Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today we are wearing matching
gazelle hoodies celebrating the launch
of the new gazelle debit card brought to
you by Ramsay is a MasterCard debit card
check it out at ramseysolutions.com
gazelle in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
is quite a few folks or a couple hundred
looks like and two of them are on the
debt free stage which can only mean one
thing that phrase James and Kat are
joining us for their debt free scream
welcome guys good to have you hey Dave
thanks for having us absolutely where do
you guys live we live in Luverne Alabama
just south of Montgomery oh cool welcome
to Nashville all right how much data
have you guys paid off we have paid off
eighty thousand dollars in 21 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time oh we range from 85
starting out we went up to about 150 and
we're back down to about 125. cool what
do you guys do for a living I'm a
hyperbaric safety director I also work
part-time with volunteer fire department
in my local area and I'm an ER nurse so
who worked their butt off because
somebody doubled your income that would
be that would be the ER nurse yeah
unlimited hours these days right yes sir
continues to be a nursing shortage
always will be yeah I think there will
be you're right and uh coveted mandates
and crap makes it even worse because
people bailed out yeah wow good for you
guys well way to go what kind of debt
was your eighty thousand dollars Dave it
was all normal it was a had a truck a
tractor lawnmower we had some student
loans we had to pay off as well as some
credit cards okay so it sounded like a
lot of it was you a truck a tractor a
lawn mower that doesn't sound like this
is the problem that was 100 mine
unless she's collecting tractors I mean
you never know these days that's true
the student loans are all mine oh okay
well that balances it out all right was
that the big one please tell me it
wasn't lawn mower no the lawnmower was
about fifty five hundred dollars um yeah
definitely the student loans are the
worst I love it very cool how long you
all been married uh almost three years
okay so what happened a year into
marriage and you said okay in the next
two years we're cleaning up this dadgum
mess we're gonna get gazelle intents uh
we uh we we decided to have a child it
was a little bit of a surprise I have a
19 year old and a 18 year old so we kind
of started all the way back over and I
made a lot of sacrifices when they were
young because of financial poor
financial decisions so I decided I
didn't want to do that with the new
child so we we kind of listened to Dave
Ramsey I'd heard about it multiple times
but I'd never met anyone who had
actually stuck to the plan and was
actually successful
um and then you know we talked about it
at first I was not 100 on board of
course
um I'm very much one is instant
gratification kind of people and uh
but I didn't want to make the sacrifices
I wanted to spend time with the new
child and not you know have to you know
Miss a lot on all the school events and
stuff like that so we we sat down and
made a budget and we stuck to it and it
was not easy no it's not easy it was not
was it worth it yes 100 what did you
sell
we did not sell anything good believe it
or not we didn't really not you just
buckled down on the old lifestyle yes
and kicked in the hours absolutely work
like no one else so later you can work
like no one else exactly exactly Hebrews
12 11. that's what we want to do so
that's what we did I did want to try to
sell my truck uh it hurt but nobody
really wanted to give me what it was
worth so I said well let's just go ahead
and pay this thing off and I'll have it
for a while there you go that's
incredible so what was the biggest
sacrifice you guys had to make along the
way
um spending time together
we we had the child and we decided that
we were not going to pay you know
anywhere from four to six hundred
dollars a month for daycare
um instead we could throw that money on
to debt and maybe accelerate spend you
know paying off the debt faster so we
actually work opposite schedules of each
other and we have for the last almost
three years now whoa um he works Monday
through Friday and I work weekend nights
wow so we this is our first family
vacation yeah all together as all five
of us together so uh
now you can set things up in a more
normal Rhythm because that was your
reason for doing it that's the biggest
reason yes to get to get their family in
balance that baby is a great fresh start
to go let's do things differently with
this one well I'd heard about you know
your principles back in
2014 or 16 I believe and I tried to jump
on it I was a single man at the time and
I don't know if I just wasn't paying
attention or just didn't want to do it
but it just didn't stick so when I found
out that I had a child on the way I said
well
I don't like where we're at financially
I know babies are expensive diapers are
expensive so you know we need to we need
to fix it so I said well
the only thing I'd heard of that worked
was Dave Ramsey so I went back and I
started reading up on it started you
know kind of buying into it and then I
went to her and she was a little
hesitant at first so I said I'll tell
you what
if you stick with me if we do this
together like we're supposed to
then at the end we're going to you know
week-long family vacation together and
she said okay I'm in now
so here we are I did I did right bribing
works I'll go with bribing bribing's
good so we came up Friday night we
stayed here in Nashville or actually
here in Franklin and today after we
leave here we're going to head to
Gatlinburg and we're going to stay in
the cabin until next month oh wonderful
and perfect timing with the leaves
changing over there yes sir yeah way to
go guys very cool very cool I'm proud of
you guys thank you thank you how's it
feel
it feels great it's a very it's like a
heavy waist lift it off your shoulders
whenever you get done
I mean you still have to stick to a
budget otherwise you'll find yourself
going right back in the dead but um it
is it's a very very good sense of relief
as for example when we got up here we
had an issue with our truck and actually
had to put it in the shop of course
um but it wasn't really that stressful
because we have an emergency fund that
is set aside specifically for instances
like this
um so we enjoyed our few days while the
truck's in the shop we had an extra car
up here with us because the kids are
going back today
um so we didn't really stress about it
too much we enjoyed our our time
together and then today we went picked
up the truck okay how big of a deal
because we stuck to the plan and we had
an emergency fund set to the side that's
incredible and now you're building for
the future instead of paying for the
past and it changes your posture an
emergency fund turns a crisis into an
inconvenience just like we said in FPU
Go figures exactly what I told her too
you know you just yawn and go okay cars
in the shop whatever yeah yeah we'll
just go get another one instead of
freaking out way to go you guys you guys
are incredible done very well done so
proud of you good stuff what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
commitment for sure I'd like to say that
owning your situation probably is the
biggest thing for me because I was the
one that went out and got the loan on
the truck you know I was the one that
decided to get the lawnmower I was the
one that decided to do these things to
get ourselves into debt you know it
wasn't my friend down the road it wasn't
my parents it wasn't my best friend so I
decided hey it's time to pull the
bootstraps up do what I have to do to
provide for my family and that's what we
did if I'm the problem I'm also the
solution yes sir yeah well done very
very well done and you know what
happened the difference in when you
tried it before or your friends tried it
before and this time was you had a big
why you had a big enough reason why you
got to have a big why and if you got a
big enough why you can do almost
anything so well done you guys excellent
job all right let's bring the kiddos up
I want to introduce all of them in the
meantime I'm gonna let you know we've
got the live and give bundle it is
called a one year membership to finish
Angel Peace University the every dollar
book or the the baby steps millionaires
book there's not an every dollar book
and The Total Money Makeover book so two
books and a one-year membership you can
use those yourself give them away or
whatever it all comes in a nice tidy box
we'll send home with you so way to go so
the kids names and ages
this is Gabriel he's 19. this is Katie
she's 18 and Quint he is two all right
way to go Clint all right I love it I
love it hey Dave real quick one thing I
wanted to point out that both of our
children here are well our older
children are going through school debt
free yeah awesome wow very good okay
lots of Lessons Learned here family tree
has changed forever already well done
you guys all right James and count cat
Quint Gabriel and Katie Montgomery
Alabama area eighty thousand dollars
paid off in 21 months making 85 to 150
to 125 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream ready three two one
[Music]
oh
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen life happens gives you a
little wake up oh y'all and you go I'm
gonna answer the phone the best part of
life is you can just decide to change I
think that's cool powerful powerful we
are still free at this moment in America
you're still free to decide this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're wearing the matching
gazelle hoodies because today is the
launch of the gazelle debit card by
Ramsey completely free no fees of any
kind you're gonna love this and we're
not going to try to sell you a bunch of
debt because we're not Sofi we're not
nerd wallet we're not going to try to
sell you a bunch of crap we're just is
what we is it's a debit card that's all
it is and it's got all the fraud
protections that MasterCard debit card
has it's got all the same features be
sure and check it out at
ramseysolutions.com
gazelle Chad is with us chat is in moo I
probably messed that up I'm see I'm uh
Rusty from being on the air here Chad's
in Minneapolis hey even Chad how are you
very good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so uh quick backstory uh divorce in 2018
um kind of found your program paid off
60 Grand worth of debt uh over a course
of two years uh last year met a new
woman and were we were married here a
couple weeks ago congratulations yeah
thank you uh so my question is is so uh
my my annual income is right around 150.
I've got life insurance of about a
hundred and sorry about 1.6 1.7 million
um
and just looking to if for some for for
anything if anything happened to me I
know for a fact that my wife my ex-wife
would go out of her way because she's
difficult and that's kind of her nature
is to ensure that there is no
relationship between my current wife and
my four children that I share with my
ex-wife so I want to make sure that I'm
I'm kind of taking care of taking care
of my kids but also taking care of my my
current wife if something would happen
to me I know I can break that out but
you know
I I under no circumstance what I what I
put the insurance the life insurance for
the for the kids in my ex-wife's name
but in a trust but you know is there is
there a good split you know is it is it
a 50 50 a 60 40 you know
you know
yeah it's just difficult isn't it I'm
sorry sorry you're going through this
how old are your babies
uh 15 to seven okay what I would do is
just split off the two issues
and how much does it take to make sure
your kids are okay if you left that
money in a trust managed by someone you
could trust thus the name Trust
uh for the good of your children
okay and set that amount in life
insurance in that and then what does
your current wife need if something
happens to you and set that amount of
insurance in her name if that happens to
total up to be the amount of insurance
you have now then you have your
percentages when you back into them
right
right and if you need more if you need
more then you can just get more
I I know that my my current wife she
would she would drastically she would
want to she I mean she would want to
move she would want she would want to
reduce her lifestyle and not and that's
not the point the the point is you
answer the question what do you want
what kind of situation do you want to
leave her in
and you create that number
and you know I just used I always just
use 10 it's a very easy number okay you
can use eight percent whatever and so if
you want to leave her with 80 000 a year
you need to leave her a million dollars
right if you want to leave her half that
and half that you know same with the
kiddos okay and um and then you
determine on the trust for the kids
obviously you decide who's going to be
the trustee who's going to manage this
money and uh I'm going to pay out the
equivalent of Child Support monthly
it'll be one of the terms of the trust
maybe a little more
I'm also going to make that trust money
at the uh at the behest of the trustee
available for a portion of a first car
for any major medical problems and for
college
and then when they reach a certain age
their portion will be released to them
and you can decide that age graduating
college is Not Unusual 25 Is Not Unusual
and those kinds of things but in no case
does The X have any control over the
flow of money except the amount that's
coming to her monthly in the form of
Child Support replacement
right okay does would it would a trust
have to be formed prior to my death no
if you can just you can you need to rot
you need to go have an estate plan done
a well done and as a part of that
there's a family trust that can be
developed that only activates in the
event of your death
right okay and then you name that trust
the Chad trust and then you make a uh
percentage of your life insurance
beneficiary to the Chad Trust
and you guys who's going to be the
trustee dude
right but but the the question would be
on you know I have to list out the
beneficiary yeah you can just put if
you've got a million six you can put a
percentage to the trust and a percentage
to your ex
wouldn't be formed but the trust
wouldn't be formed until after exactly
but it doesn't have to be that you still
name the trust and the trust is formed
only if you die now here's what's
probably going to happen it's what
happened to me anyway I did all of that
my kids grew up
that trust was never made it never was
used because they didn't I didn't die
before while they were minors
and so as an age limit on it yeah as the
last one hit 21
I did away with that portion of my will
and changed all my beneficiaries to be
Sharon because once they're 21. you own
your own baby so um you don't need life
insurance from Daddy so uh you know it
changed it all right because they don't
rely on your income exactly they're not
dependent on me I'm not trying to I'm no
longer responsible for buying their
shoes they are and so thank God
considering some of the shoes Rachel
buys but um I thought it was going to be
Daniel
but anyway you know all kidding aside
that but that yeah but you'll outlive
this more than likely
right right and it all becomes for
nothing and then you'll change the
beneficiaries at that point and by then
probably you're going to build enough
wealth you may be even dropping all of
this life insurance you might have two
million dollars in your mutual funds and
you're going to leave some of that in
inheritance to them some of that to your
current wife and that's all there is
there's no life insurance at all and
that trust that would have been formed
upon your death for the care of your
minor children never occurred because
they grew up before you died so for most
people we say hey uh will is enough at
what point do you go all right you might
need to look into will with a trust for
minor children is necessary
um you know Sharon and I had that in
case of both Sharon and I dying that
would have had to have occurred because
we were married still we weren't exes
right and so uh yeah you know uh if
either one of us died it didn't activate
only if both of us died because I
trusted her to manage the money for the
kids but he can't give that to his crazy
ex yeah complicated situation so it
changes it changes the dynamic a little
bit but the uh um last thing we want to
do is fun to crazy right with with a
million dollars here here's a million
dollars crazy that'll help you that'll
make you metal make you sane right not
just makes you crazier but yeah that
that
stuff so I'm glad he's thinking about
this because most people don't even have
a will they're not even thinking about
this stuff you're right 78 of Americans
die without a well which is dumber than
a rock okay because you leave everybody
behind you that you said you loved in a
mess in your wake just dealing with a
even if you've only got broken a car and
ten thousand dollars in your checking
account you need a will yeah people
think well I have to be
multi-millionaire to get a will in place
you need a will you need to go to mama
bear legal forms and get a will and you
can these little trust these little
Family Trust like I'm talking about and
you can put terms in there very easily
like I just dictated I even dictated in
mine back in the day that it went into
the four types of mutual funds wow the
trustee had to put it into those four
types because anyone some judge going oh
it has to be in CDs certificates of
depression
you know because I mean what if you had
your money in CDs with a 9.8 inflation
rate and you're making one percent on
your money
do you call that you know that's bass
awkward right there you're running
backwards so you don't want to do that
so I want the kids plugged into
something that's going to work there so
I had even the four types that had to be
invested in that and the income off of
that was to create to do this and the
rest of the income was to continue to
grow and you know we just dictated out
it really isn't that long you just kind
of have to think about the different
things that you want the thing to do so
you have to be intentional with it yeah
just like every other day of your life
look how that works but I'll tell you
what here's what's very interesting
there's a high correlation between
people that build wealth and people that
pay attention to these types of things
that involve managing wealth so there's
a high probability Chad in Minneapolis
is going to be a wealth Builder it's a
high probability of that not only is he
a dad that cares about taking care of
his kids not only is a husband takes
care of his current wife but he's also
thinking about the subjects of how I'm
going to do that this guy's a it's a
stud well done Chad this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsey Show Channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they actually love
and create real amazing relationships
this is a show about you and your life
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
no George and I are not strange wearing
matching hoodies we are celebrating the
launch of the gazelle debit card right
there it is baby the gazelle debit card
and I just came out from Ramsey it is
the debit card that does not try to get
you into debt it is fully protected by
the FDIC and mastercard's normal fraud
protection programs which is as good as
any credit card you could get out there
for any of those things things and this
thing is absolutely amazing it's better
than a credit card because it really
looks good and you can't go into debt
with it makes a statement that says I am
smart with money when you pull this out
people go that one's smart with money I
mean because I mean people that that
means you don't you don't you don't use
credit cards use a debit card which is
what we do it's what we teach it's what
I've always done and I've always had a
Visa or a MasterCard debit card so
having a Mastercard or a Visa debit card
that I offer is not inconsistent for you
trolling idiots out there just to make
sure you know what's up and um hey
that's the thing man so check this out
no fees no fees no we're not gonna send
you pretty commercials with pretty
people sitting around talking on a
little couch wow is that a person
no it's Sofi commercial oh yeah pissed
me off because they make it look like
they love you and they're actually
trying to absolutely screw you with
their also awful debt you know their
average credit card debt in America at
the rate here's how the how much the
banks love you in the most inflationary
period the roughest economic situation
from an inflation Viewpoint we've had in
40 years what did the credit card
companies do they raise the average rate
on a credit card from 18 to 22 percent
oh it's inflation right I mean you got
to go up with inflation right you got to
go up on there and tell you what you're
let me tell you what their trade is on
this zero not one because you can't
borrow money on stupid it doesn't work
that way with a debit card okay and uh
no fees did I mention that there's no
fees and then we're not going to sell
your name and we're not going to try to
I was just in here deleting an email
George watch me do it from some app on
my phone that I forgot to check the
stupid little box and they Market me a
bunch of marketing crap and that I
didn't want and we're not going to do
that we're not going to wear you out
with a bunch of trying to get you in
debt because if you get a debit card
with a bank you know what it's a loss
leader for them with a Traditional Bank
they're just trying they're they're
doing that just to hook you because they
want to be able to get your name and
they want to sell it and they want to
sell you stuff Jonathan starts off this
hour in Washington D.C hey Jonathan how
are you
doing well how are you guys doing better
than we deserve sir what's up
I'll laid out pretty quick for you here
about five six months ago I joined an
accounting firm of about 6 000 people
starting salary was ninety thousand
dollars plus I'd get bonus
recently organically received an offer
for 135
000 for a hundred person firm
so it'd be a pretty big jump but my
loyalty aspect of myself make it hard to
leave
I mean ultimately I think I'm leaning
towards that side of things but I wanted
to get you all's thoughts on that and
also potentially how to break that to my
current employer
okay
um more importantly than a few thousand
dollars uh where do you want to be
working in 20 years because a lot of
people who get an accounting degree if
they land a job where you landed a job
strut around like they did something
they're all excited that they got to
join that big firm it's like a Prestige
thing like you bragged about it
yeah for me it was just table setting I
really want to be a partner I want to be
part of the equity ownership
um and I had came from a smaller firm
before where I felt very comfortable and
I enjoyed the lifestyle there and the
culture the big firm was just a more of
an opportunistic jump during our time
that we're currently in with all the you
know um people moving around
so whatever what happens next time
there's an opportunity
so you need to decide who you want to be
are you an opportunist or do you want to
work for 100 person firms where this
where the soul of the place shows
yeah I mean that's part of where I'm
going towards and I think I really enjoy
the culture of a smaller firm but a 50
raise would not be too bad overall like
that jump but then the loyal loyalist
side of me is saying hey this for our
other firm gave me an opportunity five
or six months ago to jump in and join
them been doing pretty well there but
you know considering my family and
everything like that is burning some
bridges worth at 50 raise
at that point
so I'm kind of emotionally typed in a
new firm mode so heavily and also just
the the loyal side of me doesn't want to
do it either but I know it's a great
opportunity
okay
um
yeah I think you needed to redefine What
happiness is
you think it's a paycheck
and I don't
um
so uh it's not loyalty it's I I think
you're going to spend your whole life
jumping jumping jumping jumping jumping
as long as you define it based on the
rage that you're being offered because
some morons always going to offer you a
raise
all you're going to be is a jumping bean
every time there's a raise if that's the
definition of winning
and so I want the definition of winning
for you to be broader than just the
paycheck if you redefine winning and it
encompasses your new definition of
winning which is the soul of the
organization I want to actually have
human beings and not be living in a
corporate garbage mess hole which some
of the big firms are
um and they've got all this all
politically correct garbage going on
instead of actually getting their work
done and that kind of stuff and you
don't want to be in that environment
anymore and you get a raise then the
next time Corporate America comes
knocking and wants to just give you
money but puts you back into a septic
tank
um then you won't answer that call so in
other words if you take this I want you
to redefine winning to where if someone
calls and says hey we're going to give
you 175 at a thousand at a 2000 person
firm you're going to say no thanks
yeah I mean when thinking about this
process and going to the stuff with them
recently if I was given the same
opportunity say same salary I'd probably
end up going with smaller firm but just
the loyal side of me just feels
disgusted leaving that quickly yeah I
guess that's my that's that's my biggest
thing personally yeah I don't mind I
don't mind personally I don't mind you
leaving quickly that doesn't bother me
um you just go in and go this is awkward
these guys came in offered me 50 I'm not
even going to ask you all for that
that's insulting and so I've accepted
the job and I'm so sorry and you know
this is what we're doing with 6 000
people they will replace you and
eventually they'll go oh yeah that guy
used to work here in about an hour
in about an hour they won't notice
you're gone
and so I mean it's not it's really not
that big a deal but I think the most
important thing is you define what is
inside of you what winning looks like
you want to sink your teeth into don't
just repeat this process over and over
and over again it's a hollow process if
you're only dividing it on the paycheck
you need a broader a broader definition
than that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys I want to share something
exciting our team has been working on
for well over a year we've built a brand
new debit card that helps you spend and
save the Ramsay way it's called gazelle
the gazelle debit card works the same as
your standard debit card with the same
FDIC protections provided by our bank
partner password n a member FDIC with
gazelle your privacy is important we
won't sell your personal information
which means you won't have debt pushed
on you imagine not having an inbox full
of credit card offers coming at you
every week the gazelle debit card
eliminates these distractions and helps
you attack your money goals fast plus it
offers benefits others don't like no
monthly fees and a seamless connection
with every dollar and did I mention we
won't push debt on you guys your money
is your money you work hard your gazelle
intents and now your debit card is too
get the gazelle debit card and take
control of your money for good go to
ramseysolutions.com gazelle to sign up
that's
ramsesolutions.com gazelle
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just got back from a sold out smart
conference event in Dallas Texas this
weekend the house was packed with
thousands of people it was amazing our
Live Events have been epic this fall
each one has been a sellout coming up
here in November we're going to be
running around all over the place we're
sold out events in San Antonio
Minneapolis and Sacramento and our LA
and uh last week we announced the spring
Building Wealth live tour tickets are
selling very fast we sold out of the VIP
tickets in Indianapolis and Anaheim
within 48 Hours wow our Building Wealth
live events walk you through a simple
but proven plan that will help you save
money Bill wealth make smart decisions
in this weird crazy economy and despite
what the news on the internet says it is
possible Rachel Cruz Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney the George camel sitting to my
right for a night of Hope with me and
we're going to teach you about like what
normal is and how you don't want to be
normal but a way to function in this
crazy world in Indianapolis is February
16th Austin is February 23rd and Anaheim
is May the second tickets start at 39
the VIPs always sell out fast super fast
and the Platinum sell out even faster
you won't want to wait go and get your
tickets at ramseysolutions.com tickets
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself whyblinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping new promos all the time you'll
save even more use the promo code Ramsay
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from Thomas in Virginia
I'm in the early stages of becoming a
first-time homebuyer and I was wondering
if taking out two loans from separate
entities as possible for example if I'm
buying a two hundred thousand dollar
house and a family friend says they'll
give me a hundred thousand loan at a
three percent interest rate would I
still be able to qualify for an FHA loan
on the other 100 1000 from the bank if
this is possible how does this work
well aside from it being a bad idea uh
it may be possible we don't know a lot
of the details of this person's life
their income their debt to income ratio
but I would not be doing any of this
yeah number one we wouldn't do an FHA
we'd do a conventional loan because
they're cheaper uh interest rate and
fees uh number two I don't borrow money
from family friends because that's a
good way for them to no longer be a
family friend
um and so I wouldn't do that for that
reason let's say you were going to
execute It Anyway technically tactically
how do you do that well you have to
disclose the whole process to the lender
and so the lender has to understand that
you are borrowing money in addition to
the hundred thousand dollars you're
putting down as a down payment is not a
real down payment it's borrowed money as
well not disclosing that to the lender
that's making the first mortgage loan
um
is called fraud
criminal fraud because you induce them
to give you money without giving them
accurate information by lying to them
and so people do this stuff in real
estate business all the time and they
don't realize it's like go to jail do
not pass go and do not collect 200 stuff
now here's the problem okay
conventional loans only going to take a
first position meaning First Mortgage
position that means your family friend
is in second position
so let's say the world's worst
catastrophe happened
and
there was a car wreck and you were
unable to work
for for 10 years
and therefore you're unable to pay
either one of these mortgages
the first mortgage will foreclose
when they foreclose the second mortgage
holder your family friend
to protect their one hundred thousand
dollar loan they have to write another
100 000 check and buy out the
foreclosure
otherwise when the first mortgage
forecloses they lose their position in
the house
it wipes it out all mortgages behind the
first mortgage are behind the mortgage
foreclosing if it's a second mortgage
and there's a third mortgage or wiped
out
by the by the previous mortgage for
closing and so the only way to prevent
for him to protect himself is to come
out of pocket again for some more money
well that'll never happen you're talking
to people who've done this for 30 years
it happens all the time
you're talking to cancer doctors we know
what causes cancer okay and we know what
causes stupid and this is stupid
you're gonna get yourself in a pinch
you're gonna get your family friend the
pinch unforeseen things are going to
happen things you don't think are going
to happen are going to come up he's
going to get no problem and need his
money and come knocking on your door and
want his money right now something's
going to come up and you're going to be
a caller on the show looking like you
did something doofus because you did
something doofus don't do this was I
unclear pretty clear to me Dave okay
clear as mud didn't want to be unclear
but that is a scary situation it sounds
like you're not ready to be a home buyer
and that's okay but you know you're
trying you're just trying to get a lower
interest rate because the guy's trying
to get three percent on his money
and the guy making the loan and he's
trying to get a lower interest rate on
his mortgage and both of those are good
motivations but what neither one of them
thought through is all your worst case
scenarios and you know the only time
debt works is when debt works
and all the rest of the time when
everything works perfect it works but
all the rest of time which is all the
time that no it doesn't work it always
ends up coming back and biting in your
head and on paper you go this is an
amazing plan I'm a genius yeah you get
bit in your assumptions is what happens
and you know when you get bitten the
assumptions it hurts it hurts it leaves
a mark all right Donald is with us in
Spokane Washington hey Donald what's up
good afternoon Dave I got a retirement
question for you okay
um retiring from the Air National Guard
at 34 years and I also have a technician
job it's a GS with the Air National
Guard those go together I retire from
both of those next month wow they have
an automatic
um Survivor benefit that's uh it's
selected for you you paid 10 of your
retirement for me 140 a month if I pass
away my life it's 50 of my retirement
which is 700 a month uh the bad news is
if I was to cancel that because that
sounds like a horrible insurance policy
um if I cancel it she would no longer
get uh her health insurance uh if I was
to pass away there's also an option of
getting a uh paying a five percent uh
and then she gets 25 percent of my
retirement so it would I'd be paying 350
a month sir my wife would be and then
she gets her retirement with that
whether options uh are there it sounds
like a horrible insurance policy that
I'm getting pushed into
yeah
um you're right you're you're you're
actually buying health insurance is what
you're buying
right yeah I mean in a sense that's
what's pushing it
uh correct and then I have to add
another 140 a month to my health
insurance how much is the health
insurance
um for just her it would end up being
about 2 25 a month we currently pay for
my for the
to 450 a month
but if I pass away then that goes down
other than half and she can buy health
insurance for the rest of her life is
the health insurance good
uh very good actually okay all right
yeah I would do it yesterday health
insurance
okay
you know another Dynamic is I'm working
with Xander Insurance uh and trying to
get new life insurance because I'm
losing the serviceman's group life
insurance with the military and so
switching over with them they're very
easy to work with so the two pluses
there good thank you thank you for your
service man yeah I appreciate it but
yeah that's
um you're right it's just a government
program in your box stand but I would
just look at it as you know you're
buying a little you're buying uh
Guaranteed Life health insurance is
quality health insurance you're saying
for the rest of your life for your wife
and for the rest of her life and so or
the opportunity to buy it because at
their ages getting it in the marketplace
could be yeah it'd be a lot more but
um uh you know if if he told me it was
1250 a month then I would be going uh
then why are we doing this you know but
250 a month it's like a serious
reasonable so that's you know you're
that's end up being that you've gotten a
good benefit Todd with a not so good
benefit but they're tied so there you go
it's a wash Karen's with us in New York
work hi Karen welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi guys hey
so my question is
nurse so I think I know
I want to know if I should pay off an RV
uh in two years by doing a snowball on
it I have a payment on it what's it
worth or pay some or pay some super tax
what's it worth my loan is maybe 90 000.
what do you mean
120. yeah I would sell it it's a lot of
RV you have too much tied up and things
going down in value and RVs go down in
value worse than just about anything
are horrible on holding value so you got
to be able to just choke that amount of
money is what it amounts to it's like
buying a boat same thing this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on that debt-free stage Caleb
and Samantha are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve welcome yeah where do you guys
live we are from Canton which is about
40 minutes north of Atlanta yeah welcome
to Nashville good to have you guys all
right how much debt have you paid off
about sixty thousand dollars very good
and your range of income during that
time how long did that take it took
about a year one year and your range of
income during that time uh we start
around 80 and then we jumped up to
somewhere between 140 and 145. okay very
good very cool good for you guys
excellent what kind of debt was the
sixty thousand and man everything uh the
bulk of it about 30 grand was a car
um that kind of kick-started this but
um five or six credit cards A Plumbing
bill that from a house that we didn't
even live at anymore
um and then another huge chunk with
student loans so you're just kind of
collecting debt yeah it was a it was a
really good habit it was fun there's no
prize at the end unfortunately no
interest yeah interest I was surprised
how long you guys been married uh almost
five years yeah five years the 28th okay
so what happened a year and some change
ago that gave you the wake-up call and
you start on this process and one year
later boom you're done yeah so um I I
heard about you uh growing up a little
bit I just knew you as the debt guy get
out of debt get out of debt I heard you
speak uh we went to a North Point
satellite church in Andy Stanley church
and heard you speak and I told her I can
remember vividly uh before we got
married I said yeah it's really easy to
pay 200 on a tip when you make millions
wow yeah no way we could ever do that uh
so anyways long story short
um we had found out we were pregnant and
about February of 20 is that right
February 20 with uh February 21 actually
and um so it was really just pulling
teeth we grew up very differently with
money uh I saved every penny uh some
caught Financial trauma I call it being
Frugal but uh saved every penny she she
spent a lot and so it was it was
literally just pulling back and forth
Just whose car was the 30 000 car uh
this one's right here all right what
kind of car was it it's a Kia Sorrento
oh yeah
good car okay so um in that time after
we found out we were uh having a having
our second baby uh we said you know what
great idea let's do a Cash out refinance
let's it it makes sense we can upgrade
the home do everything good everything
great this is going to be awesome well
it took way longer than I was supposed
to they said my debt to income was
ridiculous and because it was it was it
was very ridiculous and it wasn't
working well we got to the point they
said to take 21 days took like three
months I was telling her I said is this
God telling me we shouldn't do this I I
don't know and uh we just kept
struggling with debt our our bank
account just kept going lower and lower
and lower no matter how much more I
worked and worked and worked and um
eventually the day came we're all
supposed to sign the papers for the Cash
out refinance the guy just didn't show
up so I called I said hey what's going
on I was supposed to sign it he says
help me call you back he calls me back
he says I have no idea what happened I
don't know what's going on we can't
figure it out we don't know I know I
showed up uh and I've been praying about
this like is this the right move and the
more I prayed the more I prayed the more
I prayed uh I got the word peace I said
we need peace in our finances Like Only
God can give us we need that peace and I
had never heard about Financial Peace
University so I Google you know
Financial Peace and Financial Peace
University it was our brand yeah and uh
so I I went through that uh in the two
week free trial of course I didn't pay
for it because I'm so Frugal uh went
through that told her about it uh
basically a total transformation our
ideas of money and she you know made
sense to her I said hey this is the last
year all the money we either do this or
we don't do anything what
so God's Providence helped you dodge the
cash out refi without a doubt that's
amazing one more bad decision avoid it
there oh so that's incredible
yeah and um so we we just uh and we
killed it from there it's uh so
um I'm a police officer in metro Atlanta
and uh I actually uh with part times we
you know you get hired to be security
for hotels uh security for apartment
complexes actually work Braves games
work for the Braves
um and I just killed it we were making I
was making 65 75 80 an hour uh you know
double triple my income and I said hey
you stay home with the kids I'll see you
in about a year
um we're just gonna we're just gonna
worry about this debt and that's that's
basically how we did it yeah you just
took every gig you could get yeah it was
incredible you had the hardest job
yeah it was rough it was rough I mean
him not
I wanted to be a stay-at-home mom at
first
um for with our first before you just
didn't want to be a single mom I said
I'm a single married parent oh yeah
that's right and then uh he told me that
we weren't getting any I total well
someone else totaled my car with me in
it uh a year before we got a new car and
I was driving his truck it was not safe
it was not great
um
she said it wasn't safe it was it was
usable but not as usable so I guess a
part of the story is we didn't do the
cash out refi I said well we got to do
this financial peace part but in between
that uh we got a great interest rate
from our uh our bank they said hey you
give we give you a great interest rate
as you pay for this car and uh buy this
car so I thought okay I guess we got to
buy this car and uh they gave a really
broke person thirty two thousand dollars
it sounds like a bank confused me really
bad really a lot of confusion there I
was real confused by that that's kind of
what what made me think Financial Peace
and kick it off too so well yeah but he
wouldn't let me get a car hour until I
got a job so then I went from that to
working and thing with the kids and my
my mom lives next door so she helped
with the kids it was just a really crazy
year that sounds like it's over the top
was it worth it absolutely yeah amen
without a doubt uh and you know there
were times in that year coming home at
three and four in the morning five in
the morning from working sometimes a
regular shift sometimes extra jobs I
picked up
you know I it was tough and and uh at
one point I thought about giving up and
she you know I had to I had to kind of
uh you know put her on board with it I
kind of had the had the thoughts at
first and and she said no what what are
what are you talking about we're almost
done with this you this was your idea
and you're gonna give up this this makes
no sense
yeah really really she really did and uh
I was listening uh to a show one time
one of your shows and um you said them
you were talking to a guy he said you
know I've had I don't know what to do
I'm he was he was desolate basically he
you said you're at a point where you're
a little tired a little pissed off and
you're ready to get going and I said I
that's where I am right now I I'm still
pissed off at the poor decisions I made
and I got to keep going sixty thousand
dollars isn't it in comparison a lot of
debt-free Screams it isn't too drastic
but it was a mountain that overtook me I
couldn't sleep at night yeah thinking
about this money that I just owed to
people I couldn't it was it was tough
and really what it was like part of that
was half of that was that one car
decision and and you were just the
regret from that was on the back of your
tongue oh yeah oh yeah and I I just sat
there and I thought how do you give a
broke man thirty thousand dollars this
makes no sense why is the same question
how does a broke man sign up
yeah
well you guys decided to sacrifice for a
short period of time intensely so that
you could win long term most people
would just live in mediocrity for 30
years and so I'm so proud of you guys
for doing that yeah thank you so much
you're amazing congratulations very well
done I'm so proud of you yeah thank you
I'm glad you did it are you are you ever
going to go back in debt we uh no we uh
the the piece of paper that we wrote our
debts our debt snowball on uh I burned
it when we finished so that's uh that's
my answer to that lock it down baby I
love it very cool very cool and the
babies bring them up what are their
names and ages uh this is uh Leighton
she is going to be one tomorrow and this
is Lorelei she's gonna be three oh
beautiful I'll tell you um just one more
quick thing uh you know the key to this
is uh within what uh our friend Anthony
O'Neill says is your wise got to make
you cry like it's got to hurt like I
grew up houses foreclosed on bills bills
weren't paid water shut off electricity
shut off but not these two no never you
changed your family amen to that yes sir
well absolutely hey we got the live and
give bundle for you it includes the uh
baby steps millionaires book The Total
Money Makeover book and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace so you can
use that or give it away to somebody and
get them started on the journey you guys
did so very well done very proud of you
Caleb and Samantha Lorelei and Leighton
Atlanta 6 thousand paid off in one year
making eighty thousand to one forty five
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
that's how it's done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Canada
is on the line Maggie is calling hi
Maggie how are you
hi good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world
well Dave I'd like to liquidate my
portfolio and
and trade on with cryptocurrent currency
and I just want your opinion
do you listen to this show
yes I do
okay what are you currently invested in
I I have uh an investment for account I
have tsfa and I have a roof account and
what has caused you to go hey you know
what I'm going to trade all of that to
go into crypto
[Music]
and um I just know that I don't believe
I'm going to come back like for a long
time like I mean they say you'll come
back but I think it's not going to come
back for 10 years and I'm already 72. so
I just feel like
um and I've also have experienced
um like it's not like I haven't I have
been doing crypto trading now for a for
a while have you seen the crypto Market
it's a lot darker than the stock market
you're trading a paper cut for a stab
well I've made money in the crypto
Market how much
um probably about ten thousand dollars
is that enough to retire on
no what's in your Investments currently
but but I've also picked um
um contracts that have been low like
lower definitely because I haven't had
money that much money to to do anything
with
as at your age I'm not gonna go to Vegas
and just put it all on black and hope
for the best that's not a great
retirement plan
that worries me
okay let me let's back up let's pack up
a second okay
you are you're scared
because your good Investments went down
and right about the time I get desperate
and scared
is the step before I get really stupid
desperate people
and highly greedy people make the worst
Financial mistakes
and your fear is making you do
statistically or suggesting that you do
statistically the equivalent of putting
this money on a roulette wheel or a hand
of Poker
because crypto is extremely volatile
extremely risky at least 100 times more
risky than your current retirement
portfolio
at least
and you're telling me Oh I put money in
the slot machine I came out with more
money than I put in uh yeah I'm not
doing it I'm not doing it myself I have
a Trader that's helping me you know like
like uh so I never close my market in a
negative position it's always in a
positive position
in crypto okay
well Maggie you do what you want I'm 62.
um yeah I my net worth is hundreds of
millions of dollars and I have precisely
zero in crypto
right and I'm not desperate and I'm not
scared Warren Buffett said and you have
it you know the idea that you have a
Trader doing it for you scares me for
you even more because this is giving you
false confidence a you've had some wins
B you have someone whispering in your
ear how wonderful they are and how they
are going to take care of you which is
how people that are 72 years old lose
everything they own
this is how it happens
okay please don't do this
but I don't think that the decision is
really up in the air I think you've
already made your decision
and if I told Maggie hey two years from
now your money's gonna be back to where
it was in your retirement account I
don't know that she would do it but it's
hard to see that far out ahead when you
just see your accounts bleeding out and
so you just want to do anything to not
be doing that one of the wealthiest men
in the world says be greedy when others
are cautious and cautious when others
are greedy
and that's Warren Buffett
and he doesn't mean greedy like being a
uh a bad person a lack of character
greedy he means be aggressive when
others are cautious and cautious when
others are aggressive and crypto is no
place to play
with money that you can't afford to lose
and you're going to lose it
and then you're gonna call me back and
say well I might have this guy who made
me you know and he's singing a siren
song and I sure hope you don't do it
honey I sure hope you don't do it uh it
sounds like this traitor is probably
telling her to liquidate give me all
your money this traitor is definitely
he's talked to her up big time he's
buttered her bread
and this guy's a freaking con artist
she's a crypto con man well we've also
have the quote from Warren Buffett
saying he wouldn't pay 25 for all of the
Bitcoin in the world no and I think he's
got more money than me you and your
Trader put together
so um you know and I don't disagree with
that at all so it's just an extremely
volatile market and that's being kind
it's crazy crazy it's what it is but um
I don't have any money in it and there's
a reason crypto is way more down well
how much is it down George do you know I
mean there was it depends on what coin
if a lot of them went bankrupted fraud
or scams 97 oh and by the way too Maggie
the number the number of people that
have the number of dollars lost not in
Bitcoin or not in crypto but in fraud
associated with crypto is what I mean
bill in the billions billions two and a
half billion dollars at this point have
been lost to Chris and let me tell you
who the number one target of the type of
Fraud and con is people over 65.
and people that are desperate and scared
empty promises and so
I'm not saying your Trader is a con
artist I'm just saying there's a higher
probability that he's a con artist than
if he was in any other business
because of the number of crypto con
artists that are out there people that
are this this thing is drawn the worst
of the worst and so you can do what you
want to do but you made the mistake of
calling here and asking and we will give
you our opinion and we are experts on
our opinion Jessica is in Michigan hi
Jessica what's up
hi um my name is Jessica and I am 37
years old and I'm a single mom of two
and
um my question is is how do I
um get the momentum to
um I'm on beta stuff number one I am
about
uh 30 or I'm sorry 17 000 in debt
between student loans
um no prob my car's completely paid off
but I'm just trying to get momentum into
getting that cash shaved up for a baby
step number one because I always try to
validate my purchases
and I'm just trying to find a way to get
the momentum to stop validating
um right now I make about a little over
38 a year okay all right what has caused
you to want to do this plan in the first
place
11 years but I've really jumped into it
more in the last couple of months um
wanting to say it was going to change my
family tree I come from a family where
where we've all not been so great with
money and um my dad actually died I'll
tell you how I did it Jessica as a
fellow Spender
yeah I looked at my kids they were
babies and we were broke because of my
stupidity
and I said I'm not doing this anymore
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired and every time I got ready to
spend
I treat I would ask myself if I had to
not spend this money so that I had the
money to save the life of my child could
I do it could I find the discipline and
that was an easy answer of course and so
I did stuff like I would practice going
to Costco and buying nothing and walking
out
and that was like a breakthrough for me
because I truly thought that if you went
to Sam's or Costco that they check your
your receipt on the way out to that it
was federal law that you had to spend
200 or you couldn't get out they
wouldn't let you out that's why they
check it and um I was that guy and and
so I just had to I kind of had to equate
it with the life of my children which is
a bit melodramatic but it's also kind of
true because you want to change your
family tree you said yeah what is 40
year old Jessica want to look back on
and say man I'm so glad Jessica made
those decisions and if that means you
know taking away your debit card
information from every website that you
have hiding it having accountability
with a friend do whatever it takes I
would think if you've got a spending
problem that Amazon Prime is not even a
possibility I'm cutting that out of my
life it's Gotta you got to turn it off
if you got a spending problem if you're
trying to say no I'm not going to spend
because I mean that's just so easy it's
easy for me you know and I teach this
stuff for a living so you just gotta you
gotta equate it with a big why and you
got to be sick and tired of being sick
and tired and then Grand gradually
you'll reform your character
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show we're dead as dumb cash is king and
the paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships George Campbell
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
the number is open open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so George a couple of months ago we did
a huge millions and millions of people
watched uh live stream for free called
the real estate reality check we address
several things in that hour and we don't
have time to address them all right now
but a lot of people were predicting 2008
again that real estate prices were going
to absolutely tank we said they are not
going to tank because there is a pool of
buyers that is much larger sure then the
pool of sellers still and the supply
demand curve will maintain the prices
meaning when you have a whole bunch of
people trying to buy a few things it
holds prices up
it's that simple when there's a scarcity
prices go up or at least are maintained
at a minimum and we said of course the
exception to that
is the areas where people are leaving in
mass and we showed a map of the number
of people that have left New York and
left California and have left some of
the high crime cities
and crazy
politics of all kinds defund the police
or whatever else cities and so uh and we
said the so far though even those areas
California New York
um Seattle Portland have not seen
decreases in real estate values that was
about two months ago three months ago
reports are coming out right now we just
got one dropped on the desk Western U.S
continues to lead in home price declines
so now California is seeing the mass
Exodus of California starting to affect
pricing there in some of the areas San
Francisco's taking some real hits 3.4
percent of the top 100 cities the city
that has taken the largest drop in price
declines so far as Seattle high crime
situation with the anarchists taking
down the entire downtown area and it
made it impossible to function
economically in that beautiful downtown
area of Seattle it's a gorgeous City or
it was was and um
the lack of Law and Order always screws
up economics when you can't operate
because people steal all your stuff or
burn it it's very difficult to run a
business it's kind of basic you know
Common Sense stuff and so these areas
are getting hammered uh their home
appreciation values dropping like crazy
meantime Louisville Birmingham Southern
cities in Texas Southeast are gone up in
value
during the time some of you predicted
that Dave Ramsey this isn't going to age
well it's going to be 2008 again the
entire thing is going to crash and I
kept telling you now here's the numbers
it's not going to crash and so we're
here to tell you the numbers are coming
out and we told you so yeah this is real
data and we use data last time too and
we're just using the newest data that's
showing that it's a it's a different
time and it's not all down some areas
are going up some areas are going down
and there are winners and losers in
other article States and yes those that
got houses when the interest rates were
super low are cheering for themselves
but those that want to get into a house
it's not too late for you either because
the competition is slowed down well
here's what prices are we have this huge
increase in 20. the record house price
increase in 21 you know 18 up right 29
up in 20 and then we said you know 22 is
going to be seven or eight percent up
which appears to be holding 9 nationally
now locally we've had some areas that
are down five percent or down 10 percent
uh we've got other areas that are up
five percent but it seems to be that
we're going to be in the five to seven
percent by year end that prediction was
made by other people but the data that
we had seemed to support it and we went
with that and it looks like that's going
to be about true in 2023 we said is
going to return to normal price
increases in homes of two to five
percent and the data is still indicating
that that's what's going to happen all
of this to say that
you're watching the news and you know
the inflation is horrible the worst
inflationary economy in 40 years right
now
and you're going to the polls in a week
or you're going to the polls right I'm
going today to early vote make sure I
you know do what I can to correct this
um you're fired that's the message and
so um
you know you can't you can't run
something you get you don't get to run
it anymore that includes your country
okay but the um anyway the uh uh all of
that aside the the the thing that's
happening with real estate is interest
rates have gone way up there on on
bumping up almost seven percent now on a
30-year fixed uh up from the threes and
you know seven percent and the scope of
a life as long as mine is very low
I remember lots of years selling real
estate 11 12 10 9 lots of years I was on
the radio it was 10 when I started this
show it was 10 and so then it came down
to six and we thought we were in Arizona
but then when it goes to three and it
goes up to seven see seven is not good
because compared to three but it's
really good compared to twelve so it's
an emotional thing so here's what I'm
telling you the other article we got was
from Bloomberg it talks about the people
that have bought homes their values are
continuing to go up especially if you
bought like in Austin Texas you know
Nashville Tennessee you bought in these
areas Dallas Texas you're buying the
Phoenix Arizona you know they've gone
down a little bit in some of those areas
in the last four or five months yeah a
little bit 16 prices too and this price
asking yeah because someone had really
gone crazy up and so it's settling it's
settling but it's not diving it's not
crashing and what's happening is these
people that bought
are going to become inordinately more
wealthy over the next three years than
people who rented
because rents are also going through the
roof
and so rents are sucking the disposable
income out of the renter's budget
where when you buy because guess what
happens to rents every year they go up
just about almost every single year
rents go up when you buy a house at six
percent or seven percent
it doesn't go up you're locking in
you're one of your largest expenses and
the value of the property is going up
because it's not crashing
unless you're in one of those areas we
mentioned right it's not crashing
overall we don't have a 2008 situation
and you're going to become wealth
inequality
based on home ownership is going to be
more and more of a thing and so what all
that is to say is if you haven't bought
a house and you're thinking about buying
a house and you're sitting on the
sidelines waiting on interest rates to
come down they're not going to come down
in any minute and waiting on house
prices to come down they're not going to
come down they're going to go up you
need to go buy a freaking house right
now it's a great time to buy a house
because there's not a lot of people
around the block trying to buy that
house right this second you're not going
to steal it
and if you're getting ready to sell a
house you need to have the expectation
it's going to take you 90 days to sell a
house right now like it has most of the
time in the history of Real Estate
most the time in the history of real
estate that's how it's gone and and so
you need to have a 90-day expectation on
selling and negotiating on your price
that's normal and if you're thinking
about buying you ought to go buy right
now and like we said a real estate
reality check you can always refi later
when the rates come back down yeah if
they come back down to three and they
might sure hope they do they'll be
wonderful and refinance and get rid of
that higher mortgage but you locked in
the price of the house
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell and I co-hosting today
things are Ramsey personality we are
wearing our matching gazelle hoodies
because today is the launch day for the
new Ramsey gazelle debit card no fees
you gotta love this thing it's a man
you're gonna it does everything the
Ramsey Way and uh you're we're not going
to lead you into debt with it so this is
not a sofa commercial and seamless
integration with every dollar which is
so cool I think that's important hey the
government's planning to hand out more
Biden bucks uh maybe in the form of
forgiving student loans maybe not but if
that forgiveness won't wipe out all your
student loan debt this is your wake-up
call because payments are coming back
and they're going to smack you in the
face when they do don't wait on the
government to fix your life Financial
Peace University can take care of you
we're going to show you how to handle
money then you are the captain of your
own ship Destiny rather than waiting on
the government to be in charge of your
life it's the proven plan to pay off all
your debts including your student loans
in just a couple of years not decades
and we've watched millions and millions
of people do this and they feel like
they got their lives back you can do it
kick Sallie Mae out of the house get out
from under those stupid loans start
Financial Peace University right now
ramseysolutions.com
FPU ramseysolutions.com
FPU Tanis is with us in Canada hi Tanis
how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um okay so I am
while I was on two but it turns out I'm
back on one so I had somebody put away
and my savings were were okay and so I
made a lump sum payment on my student
loans which was great but now like after
a couple things happened now I'm kind of
back at square one but I just feel like
every paycheck I'm reaching more into my
emergency fund because it's like I'm
always behind in each paycheck I'm
catching up from something I miss the
previous two weeks and I just like I
just can't uh I can't get ahead
what's causing you to be in the hole
right now which expenses is it
so what's your income
kind of varies so I'm on salary for the
first time in my life too which is very
different for me
um but uh yeah so like salary is three
thousand dollars a month and then I
might make another
um like a thousand dollars with just
like the extra work that I've been doing
um but that varies again so it just
depends on on kind of what's available
and what's your minimum payments and all
of your debts
my minimum payment for my student loans
is 650 a month
and then I have a 200 car insurance
payment my rent is 800
um and then I'm trying to think I have
like kind of insurance that's only like
50 bucks a month but it like the small
things are really adding up to
um
well the student loans alone
I'm 25 I just turned 25. okay
and um good all right well here's the
thing
um it sounds like hey you just started
this process
and B it sounds like when you write down
your budget that it's more like a wish
or a suggestion
well you know like yeah so what I did is
I took I I went through all my
statements from the last like three or
four months and I went through
everything that I I can't change right
now with my student loan payments my gas
like that kind of stuff and I wrote that
all down as mandatory payment so then
everything else I broke up into are they
needs or they wants and so like even
when I do that on paper it's like I only
have like two to three hundred dollars
in between each paycheck and then
something comes up if that makes sense
because I know it takes time yeah you're
doing the budget wrong
okay okay because you shouldn't have any
money left on your budget you should
have it all every dollar should have a
name before the month begins so I want
you to pan back and say I got three
thousand dollars and if you don't have
three thousand dollars you need to get
three thousand dollars in other words if
that thousand dollar gig doesn't kick in
then you got to work an extra job make
sure you at least have three thousand
dollars all right now then I want you to
write down your mandatories you got the
800 you got the 200 you got the
different mandatories like you said that
are in there I want you to give all of
those dollars a name on that budget and
decide which paycheck each one's coming
out of
yeah before the month begins I want you
to completely plan out how you're going
to pay your bills
and that includes if you have money that
is a want that's left over then you're
going to plug it in as a want
if you have money that's in need a
mandatory you're going to plug it in as
that but if you have three thousand
dollars come in and you have planned to
spend three thousand dollars exactly and
you spend it exactly as you had planned
you're not going to have a crisis agreed
yeah
but what's happening is is that
um some friend calls and goes let's go
out for drinks
right yeah that's exactly and I just see
leftover money and think it's spendable
income yeah because it's left over and
if instead if you said I have this much
allocated for social
for happy hour you know I got 50 bucks
allocated for happy hour and you did
that last week then the friend calls you
got to say no but you don't have
anything that gives you a no button all
you've got yes friends
and your yes buttons are blowing up the
whole thing
just whining you're not you're just
whining
you're just whining that's probably Fair
yeah yeah you're not saying no to enough
that's why you're in crisis right are
you working extra on top of your
full-time job
yeah like I work like like 10 to 12 hour
days depending on the day okay but for
the same salary I'm saying do you have
extra jobs
Fitness classes on top of my salary job
and so many classes as I can what's up
to 55 an hour oh that's good it just
depends on how many people show up and
if it takes time to for people to come
to your classes more and I have been
getting getting more so so you get 55 an
hour
yeah if the class is full right now I'm
averaging 45.
you're not making that at your day job
no that's like I don't know if I should
quit no no no no you need the money
right now we don't need to quit anything
we need to do more but you know it
sounds to me like I you know what I
would do is try to do 40 hours worth of
Fitness work
right you'll be tired but you'll be fit
yeah
and you won't have been going out
drinking you would have been getting fit
and making 45 dollars an hour and you
would have cleaned up this mess
right what's your total debt
UH 60 000 dollars in student loans
purely I don't have any credit cards and
I don't have a car payments or anything
so here's the thing okay we're going to
ship you a copy of the book The Total
Money Makeover and show you exactly how
to do this
what I have figured out is the matter I
get about my situation the more extreme
I get about fixing my situation
and you're just beginning to get angry
but I just want to turn your anger up a
little bit that's kind of why I was
poking at you a little bit I want to get
you mad even if you're mad at me that's
okay because I'll just be your coach
I'll be your friend that loves you
enough to take the blows okay so I want
you to go win girl and you you're smart
we're talking to you for a few minutes
you're not done doing any problem but
your your issue is focus in this extreme
Focus that comes from an extreme
sacrifice that comes from a healthy
level of anger is is really what the uh
recipe is it is a bit like Fitness stuff
um you know you tell people to do stuff
there's ones that kind of care and kind
of don't care but the ones that have to
lose weight or the doctor says they're
going to die uh they figure out a way to
lose the weight the ones that go you
know my my pants are just tight you know
they don't lose weight that's not enough
vanity is not enough to get you into a
bigger why you got to get fired up about
whatever it is whatever Behavior you're
doing that changes everything and
um you're getting there but you're just
starting this journey I've got real hope
for you I think a month from now you're
gonna be a beast oh yeah I remember when
I was getting out of debt day when I
started here and I was doing Uber I had
the Nielsen people meter to make another
20 bucks a month I was eating Lean
Cuisines waiting for them to go five for
ten on sale ooh that's gross but it was
worth it and I will never eat a Lean
Cuisine again Dave amen amen you gotta
have something you never eat again
because you had to eat it when you were
broke broke people food find that food
you know ramen noodles tuna fish for me
I hate tuna fish yeah hang on we'll send
you a copy of that book kiddo you call
us anytime we can help
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money hey if you like this show
there's three things you can do to help
us one is you can subscribe to the
podcast or the YouTube channel
two is you could leave a review on both
of those and don't leave a review unless
it's five star please we don't need your
one Stars thank you we need five stars
and you can tell people listen whether
they're listening on radio or podcast or
YouTube uh share the love you can uh in
case of a podcast or something like that
you can maybe YouTube you just forward
that share it with a friend literally
the link I was listening to my friend
Mike Rose podcast this week and I it was
about
um jobs
and about people working and I forwarded
it to Ken Coleman I said you need to
listen to this it's a good podcast and
so you can do the same thing for the
Ramsey Show guys thank you very much
Emily's with us Emily is in Portland
Maine beautiful Town hi Emily how are
you
hi Dave how are you better than we
deserve how can we help
retirement
six percent into my 401k and eight
percent into the Employee Stock Program
um my fiance just started a new job with
a much better 401K match in my job but
he makes less a year than I do so does
my Stock Program contribution count
towards the 15 retirement savings and
should we save more than 15 of his
salary if not all of it in his 401k if
we can live off of just my income
when are you getting married
uh next year okay you should not combine
your finances until you're married
very very dangerous you can talk about
them as if they're combined and you can
plan to combine them when you're married
but when uh for instance you
you pay all the bills and he puts all
his money in retirement that's combined
finances and if something happens prior
to marriage you know you've left him at
a disadvantage it's not fair
okay so you guys should run this like
roommates because that's what you are
until you're married okay and uh that it
could also actually be detrimental to
your relationship
um until you're married now once you're
married you combine everything it's just
one big lump we'll go from there now
back to your original question on the
um retirement savings we don't tell
people to invest in single stocks for
their retirement savings that's an
additional investment after you're at
baby step seven if you want to play for
some other things but um I would just
use mutual funds only uh it's all I have
done with my 401 case and so
um our rule of thumb is the best thing
you can do is get the match for you him
independently best thing he can do is
get the match the next best thing you
can do is get a Roth or turn your 401k
into a Roth and the next best thing you
can do is is a traditional and so in
your case I'm just going to beef up your
401k and make it a Roth your 401k they
make it a Roth do they have Roth option
um I don't believe so I just do a max
out of six percent and they put in three
yeah but I I gotta tell you 78 of them
offer Roth options so I bet they do you
need to check on it okay but if they get
if they don't do a Roth option take the
match and then do an independent Roth
and then go back and do regular 401K I
would not do your company stock as my
retirement plan is too speculative it's
too risky
okay
um and I you know here's the other thing
about that plan in general all Company
stock plans discount the stock price by
15 right
yep and so people think oh I'm getting a
deal on this stock but if you look at
your 12-month high and 12 month low
52-week high 52-week low on your stock
you're going to see a variant so
oftentimes most times of more than 15
percent so you're you're you may not be
getting a discount When the Smoke Clears
because of the volatility of it so no I
don't play single stocks and no I don't
do employee stock options until you've
just got some extra money laying around
and you want to play with it so to recap
here you're going to go for the match
then open a Roth IRA max that out and
then if you're still not a 15 go back to
the 401K and finish out the 15 and then
pause all of the Employee Stock purchase
program and keep your finances separate
until you're actually absolutely I come
home from the honeymoon and then you
combine everything at that point that's
what we would tell you to do and that's
what we've seen the best results from
the millions of people that we've
coached over all of these decades now if
the company is gifting you stocks and
you're not having to pay for it well I
cash it out and uh we'll take free stuff
better we always take free stuff yeah
most always uh Stephanie's in Oklahoma
hi Stephanie how are you
hi Dave I'm well how are you and George
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
you're guided over these years but today
I'm calling over something that is I
know a lot of people deal with
I have um pet fitted pet stats for my
parents before when they went on
vacation and it was agreed upon a
certain amount of money due
um to the days that they were gone you
know it was very organized and I
explained why I was charging and then
that it's never been a question this
year
um my mom and dad went again on vacation
I told them yeah of course I'm going to
keep the dog you know you can pay me
when you get back
for some reason my mom has had a slip of
memory and this is not about the money
it was agreed upon in a conversation
about three weeks ago what I was going
to charge her and I actually called and
said is that awake or has he already
gone to bed she said no your dad's in
bed I said well that's unfortunate
because I wanted him to be present in
this conversation so I need to discuss
with you what I'm charging you and why
so I explained to her the rates when
they were gone their dogs unexpectedly
had to go to the vets I missed out on a
half shift of work the vet is a friend
of mine who waived the fee so I saved
them that much money but I lost down on
a little bit
so I explained to my mom the rate it was
not any more than it was a year ago and
she agreed upon it
fast forward last night we're all having
dinner as a family and I said my mom
offers me a wallet she says I have this
old wallet do you want it it's in really
good condition I said yeah I'd love to
have that and to tease her I said you
can go ahead and put that check in there
as well
for the dog sitting for you know this
amount of money she said no I'm not
paying you that much
anyway I went outside dad's grilling the
burgers I said dad this isn't going to
be okay we already had this agreement I
wish you were present for the
conversation and I said Dad it's not
about the money it's about the principle
of the matter
and everything kind of blew up my mom
wrote me a check I left because things
were upset with my sister being there
giving her feedback and all this my
question to you is
was I wrong and
telling my mom no you need to pay me
what we agreed upon
it's a financial it's a business uh what
did I say I said it said business
ideally okay you need to keep your word
mom
and then she wrote me her check and she
was upset what was she upset about
said literally I'm not gonna pay you
more than what we agreed about you can't
change your mind I said Mom I didn't
change my mind what are you talking
about
we discussed this amount
like we've had a conversation about it
on the phone a few weeks ago and you
agreed to it so why are you angry
so later after I went home I went out
walked the dog had some time prayed
about it
ask God to tell me you know what is
going on here what am I missing I don't
understand and I called my dad later and
I said Dad I'm really at a loss right
now is mom having like memory problems
is that what's going on or what and he
said that maybe I don't know
but he did tell me that I didn't deal
with it well when I you know talked to
her about it in front of my sister
I didn't mean to like you know stir the
pot
but I just I'm really um Stephanie how
much money was this
is 350 dollars
I see two options number one we never
pet sit for them again and number two we
just go okay stupid tax I'm never doing
that not worth ruining a family
relationship yeah just call her and tell
her you're gonna tear up the check it's
not worth it and um then next time they
call it set the pet tell them you're not
gonna be able to
and because our relationships remember
is more than this horrible little tiny
business transaction
so I'm not I'm just not going to enter
into this Arena again because it's not a
place that I like to play and I'm not
very good at it so I don't want to do it
anymore
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
chronicles 15 7 but as for you be strong
and do not give up for your work will be
rewarded Thomas Edison said our greatest
weakness lies in giving up
the most certain way to succeed is
always to try just one more time
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five George camel
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
Devin is with us in Cheyenne Wyoming hi
Devin welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world
for a couple years right started listen
right after my son was born so I thought
it was time to kind of get my money
right
um we've been doing our budget and I
kind of realized I think I've been doing
my budget wrong and I wanted your
opinion on it
okay
what are you doing so well I was
budgeting as if we were getting paid uh
every two months or getting paid twice a
month such as like first and 15th to
15th and 30th but we don't we get paid
every two weeks which makes that
paycheck fall kind of obscurely
throughout the month so I noticed it
when we're going to get paid on the 28th
of this month and I noticed I don't need
a full paycheck to get through
the 28th to the 31st of October yeah
here where you get three checks
exactly and I didn't even notice that so
we've been eating into our emergency
fund and I didn't notice it until we
started kind of going wow we have all
this money at the beginning of the month
and then towards the end of the month
it's like wait a minute how are we
overspending
and then I looked at the calendar I
noticed we don't get paid every two or
twice a month we get paid every two
weeks which makes that fall kind of
weird and I want to know how to set up
that budget especially in using every
dollar
so are you already using every dollar
I am we've been using it pretty
consistently for the last couple of
years in fact now after I noticed it it
seems I have it set up all the way
through April
and so have you checked out the new
paycheck planning tool in there because
I think this could really help you
because it'll map out exactly when your
money's gonna run out
that uh the paycheck planning tool is
actually how I noticed that I was
budgeting raw that's good at least
that's perfect that means it did what it
was supposed to do good okay yeah so the
concept behind all of that and
precluding the paycheck planning tool is
this each and every month is unique
and you should start that month and look
at that month's bills
and that month's income
because you don't have Thanksgiving in
May
but you do in November and there's a
turkey involved most the time so that
month's bills are different you don't
have Christmas except in December
hypothetically
and so hopefully you should only have
that that expense there and you know in
my case I heat with gas and so in the
winter my gas bill my natural gas bill
is higher in the summer I virtually
don't have one because all we have is a
little bit of hot water and there's only
two of us in a shih tzu so we don't burn
a lot of hot water that not nearly like
we burn to heat the house right so my
natural gas bill is less in July than it
is in December so my July bill for that
should be my July budget should be
different now a lot of things don't
change obviously you got a house payment
car payment that kind of stuff there
they're going to stay exactly the same
your grocery budget is going to be close
it may have a little bit of birthday
difference or something like that in it
but you need to plan every month before
the month begins and that includes the
income and the outgo and you may and so
if you look up and say you got three
checks in those two magic months then
you're going to plan all three of those
checks
okay
um so my question would be like do you
just roll the money over so for the end
of this month like I said we get paid on
the 28th we just roll that into November
then
it depends on how you want to lay out
that November month do you want to lay
out the November month using the 28th of
October
if you want to call that the first of
November in your planning that's fine
and then okay so that's going to cover
my you know my rent that's due on the
first that kind of stuff because you're
not going to get a check for two more
weeks
exactly so the stuff that's due on the
first is going to be a pinch and so
that's what planning that month out
ahead of time causes you to look at that
and what you've been running you're
right the the thing you've been doing
wrong is you're trying to do each month
as if it was a template and it was all
exactly the same
and so what I'm trying to do is get you
to do a level of customization to each
month and then the paycheck planning
tool allows you to customize where those
paychecks hit and so oh I can't I got to
pay cable I got to figure that out you
know I got to pay my light bill I got to
figure that out and you got to put
groceries in all the different in each
each of the each of the paycheck periods
and a lot of these bills you can go in
and select a different date and so if
you're realizing too much is coming out
of one specific date or a few days you
can go into you know the website call
them and change that date for it to come
out the dude yeah utility due dates um
and the other thing you could do with
some utilities is you can do budget
billing where they level it out for the
year and then once a year they even it
up meaning they if it was a little high
they'll give you a little bit of a
refund or credit towards your next one
or if it's a little low you're going to
have a little higher bill for one month
but you can do that some budget billing
that helps as well but the big thing
you've realized is is that you were uh
you know you were not operating you're
operating on a template rather than a
custom month and the paycheck planning
tool on every dollar every dollar app
which is the world's best budgeting app
and it really is it's very robust but
this new tool is really really helpful
it's one of the most requested things
we've ever had as soon as we put it up
everybody went bananas on it and uh some
of you have set every dollar down you
need to pick it back up because you can
use that paycheck planning tool it's
going to make it a whole lot easier and
Now seamless integration with the new
gazelle debit card oh good point there
you go how cool is that Matthew in
Dallas how are you
doing well sir how are you better than I
deserve what's up yes sir I was curious
I am in a predicament and I was
wondering should I purchase a house when
it is above 25 of my income at a
six-year 15-year before roommate no
okay because roommates don't always pay
they don't always show up
there's the gaps between roommates and
you're gonna get yourself in a crack
that you buying the house not the
roommate
yes sir but but you know if you can
commit to
creating enough income with part-time
hustle side hustles to cover it and make
it 25 percent and then the roommates
icing on the cake now we got a win-win
yes sir but I wouldn't run it on
roommates because how many times have
you had a roommate
uh three times okay and all three were
reliable
yes sir well you got good and lucky
where do you find those man
that's amazing
yeah it's like Runners I mean I've had a
lot a lot of renters over the years and
these people say oh well I went to a
real estate seminar they said the renter
will pay off your investment real estate
and that's it no they won't because they
don't always pay
this plan sounds so bankruptcy that's
suspiciously close to house hacking like
a covet quarantine
you know we're really good we we very
seldom have a bad tenant because we've
been doing it a long time we only get
good tenants you know how to vet them
now yeah exactly but still same thing
with roommates would be true you know
he's done a good job I'm teasing with
him but he's obviously done a good job
selecting quality people to be his
roommate but I wouldn't put the
piece of my finances on that line would
you no and there's two options here
either increase the income or increase
the down payment and that means a little
bit of patience I'm okay with that
because when you do get into that house
you can breathe and you're not reliant
on the roommate yeah yeah and it changes
you know if you really have to have that
money from them it kind of changes the
way you look at them when they walk in
the front changes the relationship you
went you're going out again and you
haven't paid the rent yet what you
you're going the beach wait wait
where are you going Where's My Money
Where's My Money where are you going
wait a minute let's talk here for a
second oh yeah that it it you know the
money transactions do that and so you've
got to be careful it's almost like the
mom or the girl with her mom while I go
with the dogs change relationships it's
uh it's a thing it's a thing and so you
if you need the money it changes the
whole deal dramatically and it changes
the tone by which you address these
things well Dave this might be the last
day our wardrobe intersects with our
gazelle hoodies you're suggesting I will
never dress as good as you again I was
gonna
I know about you it's all right well Fun
Day celebrating the launch of the
gazelle debit card congratulations to
you and the whole team yeah it's a lot
of fun awesome cool that puts this hour
of the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
thank you
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]